miley bourgade tranquille bucolique du
sud morvan et c'est 451 habitants
incivilités et délinquance ne font
habituellement pas partie du décor
pourtant lundi à 8h45 l'agent communal
fait de triste constatation le cimetière
a été saccagé près d'une vingtaine de
tombes profanées mon sentiment personnel
bombe c'est de la tristesse une amertume
en fait ce que qu'ils vont avoir dégradé
des tombes mais bon pour l'instant moi
je ne me suis pas toujours promener dans
le village parce que déjà j'ai un métier
à côté et je peux plus faire mon métier
ça fait trois jours
les vandales se sont introduits durant
le week-end des stèles renversées brice
et des fleurs arrachées les gendarmes de
la brigade de recherches de château
chinon récupérer tous les indices pour
pouvoir identifier les coupables et
découvrir leurs motivations il pleuvait
beaucoup
donc on va dire que des des éléments ont
été trouvés des voiles enquête est en
cours je peux pas vous en dire plus mais
en tout cas des empreintes de pieds ont
été identifiées des empreintes voilà
donc à suivre au niveau de l' enquête y
compris l' enquête judiciaire mais en
tout cas comme vous le voyez sur le
cimetière des croix sont tombés je pense
que c'est ça qui marquent plus depuis le
cimetière a été fermé pour les besoins
de l'enquêté l'ensemble des familles
concernées sera informé par courrier du
maire dans les prochains jours